[Musique]
bienvenue dans l'essentiel le magazine
qui reprend toute l'actualité de la
semaine au département tout de suite
l'information en images une interface
plus interactive une navigation
accessible aux personnes en situation de
handicap
le département de la réunion lance son
nouveau site internet
c'est à la ccit base de saint pierre que
les internautes ont pu découvrir les
premières pages du site département 9 7
4 points fr sur ce nouveau site
on va proposer d'aider et d'accompagner
les gens par profile donc à des profils
agriculteurs famille entreprises et
c'est donc dès qu'on clique sur famille
de soubaya des fiches avec des mots clés
où on va pouvoir retrouver facilement
une crèche et des aides que la
collectivité propose aux internautes la
villa du département paris de fleurs et
de lumière un décor de fête pour
célébrer le nouvel an tamoul
une soirée placée sous le signe du
partage et de la découverte des
traditions indiennes
la réunion était construit
à partir de nos origines diverses et
variées et aujourd'hui il convient de
célébrer l'unité réunionnaise
à travers cette diversité le nouvel an
tamoul est l'occasion pour nous bien sûr
de montrer la culture tamoule sous tous
ses aspects culinaires et gastronomiques
musicale surtout césar aussi on avait
des musiciens de la musique et de la
danse
et c'est ça qui m'importe c'est de
montrer aux nouvelles générations que la
réunion s'est construit il y à 200 on
essaie le poète réunionnais leconte de
lisle
le conseil départemental célèbrera tout
au long de cette année son bicentenaire
ces jeunes écoliers de bras panon se
sont vus remettre des livres et de
poésie du coup être réunionnais c'est un
besoin rapanos d'un besoin à l'école dar
as sikkah donc leconte de lisle dans
bras panon dans la race il ya c'est le
plus beau projet de vie que chaque
enfant beau partage alors un réunionnais
à l'académie française auraient à
réunionnais qui signe un nouveau courant
de poésie c'est extraordinaire des
salles de classe inondées du matériel
scolaire inutilisable le collège joseph
bédier à saint-andré a souffert du
passage de la tempête tropicale fakir
cet établissement de 660 élèves a été
ravagée suite aux débordements de la
ravine sèche
cyrille melchior et jean marie
virapoullé se sont rendus sur place afin
de constater les dégâts quand on voit
les dégâts qui ont été occasionnés à
s'attendre et au collège le département
se doit d'être présent nous allons donc
très rapidement donner les moyens ce
collège de fonctionner d'abord en
procédant au nettoyage à la remise en
état des locaux
deuxième problème c'est le matériel qui
a été abîmée bureau mais aussi du
matériel informatique des matériels de
laboratoire
nous allons intervenir en direct et 6
le faut je suis prêt à dialoguer pour
lui donne une dotation exceptionnelle
d'équipements pour moi ce qui compte
c'est intervenir rapidement parce que il
y à des examens bientôt ces jeunes
collégiens et bien il ne faut pas
retarder leur scolarité
c'est pour ça que le département met en
oeuvre des moyens pour que les cours
puissent rapport rapidement d'un collège
à ses attentes
suite au passage de la tempête tropicale
fakir le président du département
demande au préfet la reconnaissance de
l'état de calamité agricole pour
l'ensemble des communes de la réunion
moi je voudrais renouveler tout mon
soutien et le soutien du département de
la réunion à celles et ceux qui ont
souffert qui ont vu des dégâts se faire
notamment
je pense au monde agricole qui a été
touché une première fois par des
guitares une deuxième fin une fois par
d'imaginer et cette troisième fois par
cette dépression tropicale s'est formée
tropicale faute fakir le département
sera là pour vous accompagner
et aujourd'hui même je rencontre le
président de la chambre des syndicats
agricoles et ensemble nous allons
travailler avec ces opérateurs
économiques
retrouvez les meilleures solutions pour
relancer notre amitié pays je voudrais
aussi dire un mot concernant les routes
départementales notamment remercier nos
services qui ont fait un travail
extraordinaire parce que dès que le
phénomène a commencé à s'éloigner
je me suis rendu sur les routes
départementales j'ai vu tous ces dégâts
qui ont été occasionnés et aujourd'hui
ben je suis depuis le dire le
département a été réactif nous avons
fait de gros efforts pour remettre en
état nos routes
et malgré tout il faut toujours rester
prudent
des binômes qui participent audio d une
journée nationale pendant laquelle une
personne en situation de handicap
accompagné d'un tuteur se retrouve en
immersion dans une entreprise chef de
file de la politique bo handicap
le département a organisé une matinée de
rencontres avec les acteurs de
l'insertion et le monde du handicap
chaque partenaire peut déjà dire définir
son rôle
l'évolution est bien sûr l'avenir de
signaux day dans les années à venir mais
comme je disais aussi il faut pas
attendre peinture day pour en parler
on peut le chaque personne peut aider
une personne en situation de handicap
chaque jour de sa vie ça représente une
chance de l'entrée
dans le monde du travail et
de voir comment ça se passe dans une
entreprise
aujourd'hui pouvoir intégrer
le département 6
une possibilité qui sera envoyé tout à
fait bien sûr je trouve que c'est une
grande chance pour nous de pouvoir
justement aider des personnes en
situation de handicap
il faut savoir que voilà souvent ces
personnes sont malheureusement rejetée
et
n'hésite en fait à avoir un homme
porteur d'un handicap
donc du coup moi je trouve que c'est une
chance que chance à la cua aux canines
chance à la fois pour moi de pouvoir
justement découvrir de nouvelles
personnes
et justement elle aussi dû donner de
nouvelles perspectives
le bonus de cette semaine c'est ce
teaser l'équipe de 9,7 iv et v vous
proposera très bientôt une nouvelle
série vidéo intitulée des routes et des
hommes
m
[Musique]
tu faisais à la main de 9 à 3 pts 5